America's love affair with cereals is
fading an estimated nine out of 10
households have cereal in their pantries
but those numbers are actually down
cereal sales have decreased over the
last five years and revenues are more
than three percent lower
jmu axis wax is here to show us what's
behind the cereal slump Jamie good
morning good morning Nora you can name
their mascots and recite their
catchphrases Trix are for kids I'm
cuckoo for cocoa puffs they're great
right but busy schedules changing diets
and breakfast options are making cereal
sales go soggy honey nut cheerios is my
cereal of choice now but when I was a
kid back if you're gonna talk cereal do
it with someone who earns their living
in the morning here's why now Gayle King
likes her cereal with bananas and reason
I would do Cocoa Krispies with bananas
and why are Cocoa Krispies so good
because after the milk it's in there it
turns into chocolate milk and I wasn't
allowed to have chocolate milk as a kid
so we said now the bowl there's just
something about a bowl of cereal in milk
it's great the Connors and I love foods
the reminders of childhood yeah
I'm Tony the Tiger but despite the warm
memories and the sugar highs cereal
sales have sagged over the past few
years
Bijan cereal out of a good breakfast
over the five years 2017 revenues
declined 3.3 percent Rory Masterson is a
market analyst who tracks the cereal
business it's still almost a ten billion
dollar industry but it's not at pre
recessionary highs in other words this
industry is it isn't crippled it isn't
going away no but people are not eating
as much cereal as they used to
traditionally no they're not our eating
habits and nutrition needs are changing
there still is a battle every day for
what's going to be eating for breakfast
everyone's got a ton of choices Scott
Baldwin is marketing and unit director
at General Mills he says the company is
changing recipes and manufacturing to
address current food concerns he points
out the Cheerios and honey nut cheerios
the most popular cereal in the United
States are both now gluten free
the same is true for lucky charms and
checks people already loved checks and
cereals and and then you introduced it
to a whole new group of people and an
absolutely benefit of the sales but not
every change works recently some cereal
companies reclaimed real sugar as a
bragging point finding that taste rules
when it comes to cereal choice we're
always trying to distinguish between
what's a true trend versus what's a fad
and there's lots of herbs and flows you
know in the world of nutrition still
there's more to the cereal slump than
what's going into or coming out of the
box as unemployment has decreased and
disposable income has increased
consumers have felt more comfortable
buying premium products and consuming
products on the go with fast food and
fast casual restaurants offering
breakfast and a country seemingly stuck
in a perpetual time crunch cereal makers
have had to adapt in order to keep up
it's why you see some favorite cereals
served up in bar form easy to eat on the
go you cannot eat a bowl of cereal with
milk in a car while you're driving on a
train or you shouldn't eat it on a train
right commuter culture is contributed to
the decline of the cereal industry as
much as anything else so you've got your
milk for your cereal from the cow yes of
course to some cereal without milk is
like a day without sunshine there's a
toast to nostalgia and to cereal into
you Jaime wax thank you how the sales go
that missed that part Jaime that was the
low thing between you and me it was such
a good your mother they don't do that we
want to release the whole thing as a
short film my breakfast with Gael oh the
nostalgia element is I mean we've talked
about our favorite cereals as kids I
think it's hard to sit at a table and
not have memories come back to you when
you deliver the cereal I can't still eat
cereal I still like it - it is good for
dinner I can't imagine it with a bar
form though it's not bad in the bar form
yeah definitely could you like honey nut
cheerios yes yes I mean all yours and
yeah yeah honey nut cheerios raisin bran